hasta este 16 de octubre estas cabañas
se extenderán la residencias de hogares
judíos con motivo del sukoto Fiesta de
los tabernáculos durante 7 días las
familias judías trasladan sus reuniones
sus comidas sus lecturas a estas chozas
que se llaman sucas y que bajo sus
creencias representan a esas nubes que
por 40 años protegieron a sus
antepasados en el desierto tras El Éxodo
de Egipto
venimos del año nuevo judío del yom
kippur donde pedimos a Dios por el
perdón y ahora él nos dice te di el
perdón que vas a hacer por mí así que
salimos vivimos afuera en nuestra su
casa dormimos aquí y mostramos nuestra
confianza en Dios
aunque estamos en un lugar frágil
tenemos la creencia que Dios van a
proteger es aquel para nosotros para mí
como judío es la creencia que tengo que
continuar
Aunque algunas ucas tienen variaciones
como estas más comerciales con logotipos
todas comparten techos elaborados de
materiales naturales sobre todo cañas de
bambú hojas y ramas la tradición es
residir en ella sobre todo comer y
dormir Incluso si llueve o como ahora
refresca por la llegada del otoño
como joven esta fiesta es muy agradable
porque estamos en familia y sentimos
algo muy especial es costumbre comer en
la azúcar pero no es obligación para las
mujeres como vemos platos típicos de las
fiestas que no cocinamos en el cotidiano
como ocurre con todas las festividades
judías está del suco también tendrá su
afectación para los palestinos al
gobierno israelí cerrará todos los pasos
con gaza y cisjordania tanto Este primer
día de sucot como el último la medida
llega luego de que este viernes y sábado
las fuerzas israelíes mataran a cuatro
palestinos menores de 19 años esto en
cisjordania mientras que una soldado
israelí también de 18 años murió por las
heridas causadas por un ataque palestino
en un checkpoint en jerusa